انتقدت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه عدم تطرق
مجموعه السبا لمعارضه استقلال تايوان
وقالت في بيان ان التواتؤ مع القوى
المؤيده للاستقلال يؤثر على استقرار مضيق
تايوان واضاف البيان ان مجموعه السباعي
استخدمت القضايا المتعلقه بالصين لتشويه
سمعتها والتدخل في شؤونها ووصف ذلك بانه
عرقله للسلام وتقويض للاستقرار الاقليمي
بحسب البيان
اما وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
فقال من جانبه انما يجري اليوم بشان
اوكرانيا يسارع الانتقال الى عالم متعدد
الاقطاب وفي كلمه خلال اجتماع لمجلس
السياسه الخارجيه والدفاعيه الروسيه اضاف
لابروف ان الولايات المتحده تستخدم ما
يجري في اوكرانيا لتعزيز تاثيرها واخضاع
الاخرين
اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار التحركات الدوليه
فانما يجري اليوم في اوكرانيا يسرع
الانتقال الى عالم متعدد الاقطاب استخدمت
الولايات المتحده الازمه الاوكرانيه
لتعزيز تاثيرها وعلى الاغلب فعلت ذلك
لاخضاع الاخرين وبالنظر الى الخط الذي
يقسم بين الغرب من جهه والشرق ودول الجنوب
من جهه اخرى فقد قيل لي خلال النقاشات
الاخيره بشان الاتحاد الاوروبي انهم
اقترحوا رفض اي استخدام لصيغه الجنوب
العالمي الذي ليس الجميع فيه مؤيدا للغرب
ويتعاون بعضهم مع روسيا والصين ودعوا لعدم
التعامل مع هذه الدول لقد وصلوا الى هذا
المستوى من التعامل للقضاء على اي اراء
اخرى